thank you thank you very much Mina and
every morning - to everyone as Mina has
already said the Commission has taken a
number of infringement decisions today
and as was mentioned also quite some of
them come under my portfolio because
there are environmental infringement
amongst the tasks which President
Juncker gave me for my mandate was to
improve the implementation of our
environmental legislation infringement
procedures are a very essential part of
this in the cases where Member States
despite the dialogue that we have with
them and the support that we give them
do not implement and do not enforce our
commonly agreed rules this commission
does not take decisions lightly we weigh
the options carefully and we are never
happy to go to court but sometimes it's
the only way it is what it takes to
achieve results during the course of my
mandate we'll have been very vigilant on
nature protection and today we are
asking many member states to step up
their efforts in this regard the Natura
2000 network of protected areas is on
the frontline in our fight to protect
biodiversity but there are still
important gaps in the network itself and
in the way that the protected areas are
actually managed and this is why we have
decided to today to refer Greece to the
court but also to click in steps against
a number of other member states and we
also take legal steps against some
Member States for not properly
protecting a series of specific
protected species and their habitats we
are also fighting to protect tulips
waters that is why we have referred
Sweden to the court today Albin
wastewater must be of a standard that
poses no threat upon reintroducing it
into the environment and we are sending
a warning to Germany that further
measures are necessary to implement
ruling on protecting our waters from
nitrate pollution but one thing in
particular stands out throughout my
mandate I have always been very clear
about the importance of human health in
this area there is no room for
compromise and it's especially true of
air pollution
last year in 2018 we set out a new
approach to the problem stepping up
engagements with member states to
protect citizens health and the
communication which we called a Europe
that protects cleaner for all one year
later the evidence of harm from air
pollution still continues to grow there
is no more room for excuses we need to
see decisive action today for example we
are calling Bulgaria and Spain before
the EU Court of Justice for problems for
issues with air pollution in the case of
Bulgaria the referral is for so2 for
sulphur dioxide the daily and the hourly
limits are persistently being exceeded
and the southeast zone limits that
should have been observed since
accession way back in 2007 for Spain the
reference is for a persistent breach of
EU rules on nitrogen dioxide and no.2
which have been legally binding since
2010 the problem areas are basically
three mainly three Madrid Barcelona and
balanced by ich leo Braga
we are also accelerating infringement
procedures for other member states for
the air quality monitoring network in
Romania for particulate matter in Poland
and for the state of air legislation in
Croatia we are taking these steps
because air pollution is still the
biggest environmental health problem in
the European Union responsible for some
400
thousand premature deaths each and every
year it also causes a range of health
problems including asthma cardiovascular
diseases as well as lung cancer and it's
a major economic burden as well with
direct cost of over twenty billion euros
each year these problems need to be
solved and they can be solved when the
political will is dead the Commission is
helping whenever it can facilitating
dialogue and funding programs that
tackle air pollution but there are still
places that need to take stronger action
as soon as possible
infringement cases and an appearance in
court can bring that point home EU
legislation is not bureaucratic it's not
abstract and it's not about what happens
here in Brussels
it's about solving real problems it's
about improving people's lives wherever
they are and that's why we are here
today thank you very much thank you very
much commissioner